so we have only fans and then we have
like the sex work industry and then we
have like actors is there a difference
between these industries or are we all
fundamentally selling our body in some
way honestly i think that selling your
body like if we're going by that
definition being in the army is worse
than being on only fans wow you're
selling your body to the government
what do you think
just before this z-wave is a show i
think on hbo i did go watch the rest of
the episode just to make sure i'm not
missing a
clip and that is the full context of the
clip i know about the equivalent of
people uh that were in the army
that were deployed that people are only
fan i know more people that are affected
by their deployment than the only fan
thing
i'm not saying that some people are not
affected by the only fan thing oh yeah
there's some people that are
absolutely uh but the army thing and
being deployed
yeah definitely more people the ptsd
that i've seen from people from the army
and the help that you can get after that
i've seen it worse in the army like not
being able to work not being able to be
outside
fireworks [ __ ] sometimes
[ __ ] cannot hear foreign
languages whereas
only fan you do sell your body but you
kind of like this kind of a control you
control where you want to go
you know i mean where
sometimes in the army you're
indoctrinated into going and doing some
doing some [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] up [ __ ]
sometimes you say people people tell me
sometimes yeah but would you rather like
you don't respect people in the army
like would you rather your girl your
little girl be on only fans or
be
in the army like i respect both of them
my point as a dad is i don't want my
kids to be hurt so yeah i'm gonna be
there's gonna be a sense of pride that's
gonna be like she's in the army she's
doing something but not so much because
i know what can happen there i know how
it is for a girl in the army i know how
it is going to be when you're going to
be deployed so
yes
mostly no okay when you say the
equivalent the equivalent in one sense
of uh mentally to risk the pressure and
stuff like that like there's pros and
cons and stuff that so saying that you
know
it's just that one is very glorified and
the other one it isn't which is fine but
i can reckon that both can be
dramatic dangerous
there's some risks
to your health and your body
to your mental health and your body so
like i i'm like man yeah [ __ ] up but
[ __ ] up so we have only fans and then
we have like the sex work industry and
then we have like actors is there a
difference between these industries or
is there a difference
if you're viewing this through the lens
of what's best for me individually
speaking then i would argue that her
argument makes perfect sense you have to
understand what you provide to the
ensemble okay i don't think you can
think of
i mean sure you can look at foreign
policy but we shouldn't have been here
we shouldn't have been there but in
terms of the importance of having a
military in very difficult times we can
all say the great things today like
we don't need one right now we're not
going to war you don't need one till you
need one
and when you need one you need one think
of world war ii
and try to say this goofy [ __ ]
while you got the enemy breathing down
your neck talking about invading and
murdering your wife and children
which one you thinking of
it's easy to say this stuff in times of
peace this isn't the [ __ ] on only fans
model this isn't [ __ ] all this stuff but
sometimes in an effort to prop up only
fans models and these people who work in
this industry to say like they're
workers too all this stuff they start
making some absurd claims you can say
you don't like the army you say you
don't want to be part of it you say you
don't want to do a lot of this stuff
that's fine in order to maintain your
freedoms you're going to need that
yeah you're going to need that and
you're going to wish for heaven because
it's easy to talk all this [ __ ] when
it's safe when she's the fan you know
what ends up happening who they start
looking for and ain't ghostbusters okay
you can talk all that [ __ ] about you
want about police and that's fine i'm
not mad at it but understand when
something happens at your home you still
call 9-1-1 she just said that it was
about the same now she's not saying that
we should abolish the army or [ __ ] the
army or the army is not necessary that's
not what she said she said
in terms of selling your body we're just
talking about selling your body so we
have only fans and then we have like the
sex work industry and then we have like
actors is there a difference between
these industries or are we all
fundamentally selling our body in some
way honestly i think that selling your
body like if we're going by that
definition being in the army is worse
than being on only fans wow you're
selling your body to the government
that's what they said in terms of
selling your body would you say that
this equals that or is it about the same
only selling your body if you talk about
protection absolutely that's some other
[ __ ] maybe i'm maybe i missed something
maybe
you you can't just take a comment in a
vacuum because everything exists within
a greater context mia khalifa has been a
champion for the sex work industry
what i mean she's been in it and out of
it because i thought she was about to go
mia khalifa was a bitter champion
she's really not
no she's really not them videos are
[ __ ] overrated okay let me just say
if it was uh
vehicle if it was just
mia simone nobody gave a [ __ ] as soon as
they put a hijab on the [ __ ] everyone's
like
right like that's how these people jerk
off to this [ __ ] that's why they put her
in a hijab in a lot of these videos
whatever you did you think again not the
[ __ ] on the army i just tried to discuss
point of views here yeah don't get too
personal yeah so you about your veterans
highlight this one
holiday
make sure i put his histogram right here
on the screen y'all can talk your [ __ ]
and only fans models holla at me
[Laughter]
we can argue as much as y'all want uh
you're not i don't support your industry
but i might support you individually
you know what i mean
all you ladies out there the only fans
of my one be like yo thank you for your
service you can thank me in different
ways
[Music]
and what i would say even like beyond
that when i hear you're selling your
body to the government it really is like
a slap in the face of all the soldiers
who do this [ __ ] because they want to
protect them go ahead no don't go ahead
finish yeah it really is a slap in the
face and all the people who really do
take their oath seriously in the sense
that they want to protect the homes
people back home
promise you right now the ukrainian
people don't talk that way about their
military
but it is a sacrifice
right but when you say oh you're just
selling your body to the government
that's where it kind of comes off a
little bit weird you know what i'm
trying to say
i understand but
go ahead
test what it is you're a product of the
government there's some t-shirt property
of the army there's the
i mean
you sign it everything about it is this
right i mean
you're disposable to the government now
once you come back there's not a lot of
hate you know i mean so
i mean yeah it's [ __ ] up and it's
slapping the face but framing is what
i'm keying in on i don't disagree with
what you're saying you can technically
say that you can technically say that
about everything oh i'm here to serve
the people actually you're here to be a
weapon of the government to oppress the
people you could frame it that way yeah
you can frame anything anything but how
you choose to frame it says a lot about
how you view the people i'm not here to
look at majestically there's people in
the army who only there for the money
there's people in the army who got
[ __ ] up prides but there's also a lot
of people who are honorable people who
do it for the right reasons but i could
say the same thing about sex workers i
could be like hey some of it do it for
the money somebody do it only
exclusively to help disabled people some
of them do it i could say the same thing
let's be honest
let's keep it a stack sex workers do it
for the money you disagree with that no
no okay but when i hear people talking
about like literally laying your life on
the line
to protect the freedoms that people have
to live by yeah wow you're selling your
body to the government
and then you just talking about that to
me it's just the greater context of the
conversation that i see unfolding online
when people talk about it and i promise
you people weren't talking about the
military like this after world war ii
they weren't yeah they looked at the
military as a result of their sacrifice
didn't go like well oh the [ __ ]
strong arm of the government it's like
no these people went to go die for you
so you can go out and [ __ ] your wife on
the weekends that's why they went to go
die so your wife can go out and get a
job and live her best life that's why
they went to go die
some of it did for a paycheck but who
cares i don't give a [ __ ] why to be
honest with you at the end of the day
they take the ultimate sacrifice so you
can enjoy your freedoms
okay absolutely now i always say this
man but in my limited time in the
military i met the best people and i met
the worst people yep some of the most
self-sacrificing
selfless [ __ ] people who like put a
whole team on their back and do
everything
as
my time in the clubs i've worked uh i've
encountered the best horrors and the
worst horse
some of them that would put a team and
put a whole team inside them
but hey hey you got to do what you got
to do and you know you do it for the
people right and then you also got your
american psychos literally like people
who should be in jail right
and hand it around like whoa that's his
person i mean hey listen you guys want
to see his discussions debates going
against each other he's got his side i
got my side he's good you know we don't
always have to disagree which one do you
guys
land on how do you guys feel about the
whole thing do you think i unfairly read
into the conference god damn you went in
[ __ ] you you yeah you took a hit
what do you mean oh
bing bing bing bing bing bing bing bing
what do you mean i heard it
it's it's a court it's it's a court a
soft spot
this [ __ ] um
to be fair
to be fair to be fair it's not like i
have some super strong affinity for the
military i'm not out here writing for
these [ __ ] like
because i will tell you i'll be the
first one to say there's a lot of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] about them oh absolutely um
i just
when [ __ ] are willing to die
for you don't spit on them true military
whatever the [ __ ] it is i don't care
it's like even like the the
self-sacrifice that men are expected to
take for their partners their families
it's like yes okay we have a duty a
responsibility i'm cool with it don't
spit on that [ __ ]
don't spit out and don't take it for
granted either because those people that
go and die for you or whatever they got
families back home who are going to
mourn them forever they got plenty of
people and somebody got to do that
[ __ ] job because if they don't when
people come banging at your door there's
going to be nobody protect you you hear
me so that's the only thing don't spit
on that that's all
what
what was going on
yeah
[ __ ] willing to die for you
don't spit on that
and if a [ __ ] want to swallow
and choke and you know die for you spit
on that
i've definitely had only fans models who
like they turn everything sexual like
you can be given the most fiery speeches
like oh my god zaddy
yes
you like rifles i want your rifle inside
you can shoot a couple make sure they're
not blanks though they're like like this
is give me listen to any speech and
these hoes will just be like ooh
i love the way daddy bought he said he
was going to iraq i wish daddy biden
would do the same thing and get inside
like i was like whoa
you don't know what i'm talking about
yeah we're getting inside my rack
there's some weird [ __ ] out there you
know
oh bye
yeah all right that's what i think
you know what's crazy it's like
convenience we sometimes go do [ __ ]
comedy shows for military yeah
yeah we do i was about to i was supposed
to
talk about these hoes not doing only
things tours for these [ __ ] they used
to no you're not saying yes they do
under the table no no
no they were literally under the table
okay oh seriously
i guarantee you [ __ ] and felucia would
probably be like yo y'all want to see
comedian [ __ ] rick scott come through
like sure we need a show let's get
american here he's like what about 10
only fans shut say no more yeah say no
more
yo tell ahmed to take the sheep and get
the [ __ ] off the fob
my rifle is polished you know i just
think i think you approach it
differently that's all oh you know what
i mean all these things about you want
you want to change your perception
do for the troops
literally do it
i know there's definitely
no you already know there's only there's
a lot out there somewhere i give a
special promotion over all the returning
troops i suck all your
you already know that's a promotion out
there i'm out here giving you a
marketing idea that's how much i support
you
he don't